bienvenue à manosque le pays de jean
giono c'est ici en provence qu'il a vécu
et travaillé toute sa vie
cette archive de 1957 témoigne de son
attachement à la région
l'auteur achève son livre provence et
pour l'éditer il n'a pas à aller très
loin
comme nous l'expliquent ce journaliste
car il a trouvé pour l'aider la
collaboration de son voisin et ami
antoine rico l'imprimeur
un peu plus loin quelques autres
s'affairent c'est l'artiste lucien
jacques qui a exécuté les 25
illustrations du livre et qui sous nos
yeux tir l'épreuve de l'une d'entre
elles un trio manosquin au service d'une
seule et même peuvre et ce n'est pas
sans une pointe de lyrisme qu'on nous
présente dans cette même archives la
source d'inspiration principale de giono
jean giono lee provence jean giono naka
aussi tourner les yeux vers sa fenêtre
pour la voir surgir éternelle et
sauvagement bay alors la provence pays
de ses rêves
eh bien pas du tout aussi étrange que
cela puisse paraître jean giono l'enfant
provençal n'aimait pas son climat
d'origine le seul de mes frais me
repousse un peu par son soleil je n'aime
pas le seul j'adore la plus essuyer les
petite brume et j'ai trouvé le pays qui
auraient quel pays de mes rêves à
l'ecosse s'il est né au mauvais endroit
giono aura en tout cas compter et décrit
la provence
réelle ou fantasmée au fil
d'innombrables pages une provence qu'il
oppose fermement à celle des clichés
celles d'auteurs pourtant célèbre qui
n'aimait guère
il ya deux provinces où il ya la
provence comme nous avait dit de juin
car strahl et puis à l'autre provence
qui est celle qui a été décrite par les
grands écrivains celle là c'est une
provence à la mesure humaine c'est plus
la provence en acajou de l'afflux c'est
ce regard loin des clichés cas précis
ses lecteurs
écoutez en 1969 ce couple d'éditeurs
installé en provence qui adulent giono
et en discute avec un ami épinglé
justement les gens de la région avec
tellement de vérité que son nez
criant hallucinant hallucinant c'est ça
et il parle aussi des paysages comme
personne n'en a parlé
moi j'avais pas envie de lire jeunes
hommes dans ce pays
et puis finalement étant dans le pays il
est la seule source
sa seule source et sasso et oui c'est la
chronique du pays ait jamais caricatural
ramenés quelques heures après la mort de
jean giono survenu dans la nuit du 8 au
9 octobre 1970 son ami le romancier
henri bosco provençal également lui rend
un vibrant hommage et du roule quand
même l'écrivain provençal non pas un
beau l'écrivain provençal la provence et
le génie il faut le dire et je crois que
c'en est une oeuvre qui restera du moins
en grande partie
[Musique]